- You can find full bios of
everyone here in your programs
already, but let me just say
that it's wonderful to have
people back at Radcliffe.
I think it's wonderful to
have people come back home,
and to think of
this as a home base.
And again, oh, the
puns, the bad cliches
will come flying when you
start talking about sports.
But it's real, too, and
we are happy to have you
back, and thank you so much.
Martha was Radcliffe
fellow in '09.
You know she teaches
at Holyoke College
and she is the
author of Curveball,
the biography of Toni Stone.
Lydia, wow-- Lydia is
also a Radcliffe fellow.
She is an award-winning
playwright
and I think her work
speaks for itself.
Many of her plays explore race
and gender on different levels.
And she's known here
at the Huntington,
the Goodman in Chicago, and her
plays have been across country.
Megan-- thank you
so much for joining
us as well-- is an
accomplished theater director
with many credits to her name.
She's worked with Lydia
on several other projects,
and I think that synchronicity
was really helpful
in this process.
And she also works and consults
with arts organizations
to improve diversity
and inclusion.
And Nambi Kelley is our
Toni this evening, our star.
She has many TV credits and
stage credits to her name.
And I think it's also important
to point out that you're also
a playwright, right?
And that you're working on an
adaptation of Toni Morrison's
Jazz.
So we have quite a distinguished
group here with us.
And I kind of just wanted to
start off by asking you all--
I was trying to find
some commonality here
that we could begin
around sort of telling
the story of Toni Stone and
this idea of storytelling.
And each of you tells
stories in different ways--
as an actress, as a
historian, as a playwright,
and as a director staging
the stories as well.
And I kind of wanted to
think of this as something
to sort of reflect on how you
go through that process, how you
sort of discovered Toni Stone.
Maybe starting with you Martha,
from the historical point
of view, getting a sense
of how you realized
that you had a
historical story to tell
that was important to you and
would be important to others.
- Well, I just
first wanted to say
it's grand to be back
Dean Cohen, Judy.
I wrote Curveball here so it
feels very, very wonderful
to acknowledge that, the support
I got and the gratitude I
feel for this wonderful place.
I knew I wanted to--
I'd finish one book, I knew
I wanted to write a sports
book because I love sports.
I think it's a great
lens for telling
multiple kinds of stories.
And I just heard this--
I had heard this tag of the
woman who replaced Hank Aaron.
And that's all I knew
about Toni Stone.
And so I did some
basic research.
To write a book,
I felt that I had
to meet three criterias,
three rings of the story.
First, was it a good compelling
story about baseball?
Was there a narrative arc?
Was there enough drama to it?
And I thought certainly
there was that.
The second ring was
more complicated.
David Halberstam the great
nonfiction writer once
said, "behind every
great sports story
is the story of a nation."
And I think that's
quite right if you
think Muhammad Ali, Jackie
Robinson, Billie Jean King.
And so I think Toni's
stories provides
that kind of look at
the period post-war
before the major events of
the Civil Rights Movement
to look at Jim Crow
America through, obviously,
the lens of gender.
What was it like
for a woman who had
this notion of doing something
that was not supported
by the culture,
that was sabotaged
by some members of her own team?
And then lastly, I felt it
had to say something about who
we are as human beings.
And I didn't know
the answer to that.
And it took a lot of
interviewing former players--
old guys in garages and
their basements telling me
the story--
to find out what that might be.
And I met this one guy
who played with Toni.
His name was Thomas
"Taterbuster" [? Bert. ?]
And we had an interview.
Interviewing was winding
up and I asked him
what he was doing now.
And he said he was
teaching his grandkids,
coaching them, Little
League baseball.
I said, what's the hardest
thing for them to do?
He said, hit a curve ball.
And I did not know
exactly what he meant.
I played softball,
but I didn't, I
don't know the strategy of it.
So, he said, stand
up let me show you.
And he pretended
like he threw a ball.
And he said, to hit a curve
ball you have to step into it,
not lean away from
it, which is kind
of counterintuitive to what
you think you should do.
And months later, then that was
the third ring for me-- what
does this story tell us?
- I should probably
put that in the play.
- What's that?
- I should probably put that
in the play, very good telling.
- [LAUGHING] Well, especially
because it took me like a year
to think about it.
- I'll try and work that in.
- But I think that that larger
question of what is this--
does Toni's story tell us about?
What does it mean
to be human-- is
when life hands
you one imperfect
chance to live your
dream, what do you do?
You step into it.
- Go ahead.
- That was beautiful.
- Yeah, that's beautiful.
- Beautiful.
- That's just
absolutely beautiful.
So, Lydia, you took
this frame where
we have Toni actually
telling her story.
What was-- to me--
is there is there
a kind of counter storytelling
going on here as well?
A kind of reclaiming a
narrative about baseball
in a way that's adding to
the voice and the history
of baseball and--
- Well that's the kind of thing
people say about playwrights,
not something playwrights
say about themselves.
I would say that
my job, after all
of this beautiful foundation
that Martha has laid down,
is to then put it into a
ridiculously short form,
and make you laugh and cry,
and feel inspired enough
to talk about it later.
I want to celebrate--
the reason I was compelled
to write the play--
Pam McKinnon-- who really tried,
and was texting me the whole
time, and had made it
all the way to LaGuardia,
and it just wasn't
going to happen--
called me with Samantha Barry,
the producer of this piece.
And they had gotten the
rights to this wonderful book.
And at this time I didn't know--
at that time I didn't know that
Martha was a Radcliffe fellow,
but I was going
into my fellowship.
In fact, I might have
just been applying,
because I think it
was in the application
that I was going to--
Yeah Judy.
Judy is like absolutely,
it was in the application.
- Wow.
- So there was all of
this synchronicity.
And I was saying
no to commissions.
I was a little over-commissioned
and I'm slow writer.
And so as soon as I heard
the story, I was sort of--
it was disappointing that I
had never heard of this person
before.
And felt sort of like
my responsibility, which
is as self-aggrandizing
as if I'd said
the sentence you led in with.
But there it is, so.
Do you want more?
I think that's all I have.
[LAUGHTER]
- That's fantastic.
Megan, maybe you
could add a little
about taking it off the
page and giving it this form
that you did this
evening, as a director.
- Yeah, sure.
I mean, so, if Martha lays
the historical foundation,
and Lydia like condenses it into
a story where we laugh and cry,
it's like we put it into bodies.
We embody it.
And you have to-- like each
moment of telling the story--
and we only got to work on
it for four days or whatever.
Even in that, each moment
of it, in an embodied way,
is taking that history--
all this social,
cultural, political,
and racial economic
history of these people,
and of this moment, and how they
relate to us and our moment.
Because we're in our moment
as we're in real time.
Yeah, that every second
of that is embodied, so.
- I kind of wanted--
I didn't get a chance to say--
these are such talented people.
And I know, you applauded them.
And I know you know
they're talented.
And they gave a really
good performance.
But there's a sort of precision,
and a very specific kind
of knowledge, and embracing
of skill and training
that I think the
parallel between what
an elite group of actors do and
what an elite group of athletes
do.
And so it's been a pleasure to
be able to work with people so
at the top of their game.
And I'm incredibly
grateful to the Radcliffe.
Because, I mean, look--
generally when you
workshop a play,
people don't say, come,
be in this gorgeous room.
And we'll put in
this gorgeous hotel.
And you can eat
really good food.
They fed us all day.
So it's a nice way, it's a very
cushy way to develop a play.
And it's great that
I was able to do it
from the birth of this
play all the way through.
And you gave me another workshop
somewhere in the middle.
And now to be here--
and thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
OK, I said that, and to Megan.
- I think I was
pretty much that--
so, talking about
embodiment and the way
that all of the different layers
of what you guys are up to you
has to be embodied, both in the
individual body of each actor,
and in the overall picture
of what we're doing.
There's something that's so--
I mean, I'm not
saying there isn't
layers to a play about a
family in a living room.
But there's such a--
this is the epic
scope of this story,
both in terms of the scope
of the game of baseball,
and in terms of the scope
of all of the history
that you've described,
and that Liz
described that it represents.
Every image, every
gesture, everything
is really heavy
with all of that.
- And can I do one more
thing, like that, that I did--
is to say that the
elegance of the gestures--
I mean to do a reading is so
challenging, because you're
communicating something
that generally you
would see play full out--
and that she had these very
eloquent and precise gestures.
You were there, right?
- That's fine, yeah
- So I thank you for that.
- That's good.
- Good directing.
Thank you.
- That's great.
Nambi, what was it like
to actually play Toni?
What kind of obstacles did
you see in your preparation,
and also for her,
that she was facing?
- That's a big question.
So, I would say, in terms
of the continuum of what
has been laid before me, which
is you start with the book,
and then you break
it down into a play,
and then you break it
down into the director,
and then you put it in
the body of an actor.
For me the biggest joy--
I, too, did not know
who Toni Stone was.
I grew up a huge baseball fan.
Go Cubs.
So sorry, Boo.
- Uh huh.
- So I kind of was ashamed
that I didn't know who she was,
but equally delighted
that-- wow--
you get to discover
this wonderful person.
And so it is such an
important part of the history.
And so, for me, it was like,
oh, I got to find out about it.
And I found out about
it, and I found out
about Mamie Johnson, and then
all the other people that
came after her, the
woman who replaced her.
And was just like--
to part of me, it was like,
yay, this is so much fun.
Thank you, Lydia,
thank you, Megan.
Right?
But then, as we got into
the process-- so I did that,
I read the play.
I want to read the book,
but we didn't have time,
because this happened so fast--
but I will.
That for me it was--
I'm a kind of actor that I
like to do a lot of research.
And I like to be very precise.
And I like to layer stuff in.
So for me, I'm actually
kind of disappointed
in myself, because--
- Ooh!
- --the athlete in me,
because I did used to run.
The beauty of having a process--
this process-- is that we get to
share with you a piece of what
this is.
And literally, that was an
edited version of Act One,
right?
But for the actor, everything
that we've talked about
is so layered.
And it's so complicated.
And it's so rich.
And so, today, what I
spent my morning doing--
we talked about--
Lydia said, oh, she
might be on the spectrum,
on the autism spectrum.
And so I spent my
morning watching
videos of different people with
different levels of autism.
And was thinking, well they
say, well sometimes he goes--
So, I say, here
comes Sydney Pollack.
So this is how-- you
know, so like trying
to find that sort of
specificity in such a short time
is like, oh!
You know, there's just so much
more we could do and layer.
And so, like it's a piece of it.
And for the actor,
it's a piece of it.
And so, as the
actor, I can't think
about I'm playing history.
I just got to be in the moment.
But I certainly layer all
of that into it, absolutely.
- It's so funny to listen
to you speak so humbly
of the truncated
process that you had,
and all that you would do.
Because I would text
Nambi my appreciation--
and I texted her and I
said, I learned so much
about the process of writing
watching you be an actor.
And again, back to the precision
that I'm talking about.
But you can see, in the
rehearsal room, Nambi leering--
this and that.
And then, also, Nambi,
it's an athletic endeavor
to do what you just did.
I mean, to carry this thing
with all those words--
anyway, it was so
beautifully done.
And thank you.
- Thank you.
I guess the thing is
that I wanted to--
I'll shut up.
[LAUGHTER]
Just say, just be quiet.
I said it already.
- Well, Nambi, I
want to build off
what you're saying
here a little bit,
about sort of
finding these layers,
and relating that to sports
in some way as this very
powerful element of society.
And I think, oftentimes, we
think of the power of sports,
we think of the NFL
large, large, large money,
big business.
But sometimes, I think the
power of sports in this case
is really captured so
beautifully by you and Lydia
in that first scene, when
she's touching the ball
and she's feeling it.
And Lydia's sensuality
is sort of--
I feel like it's moving
through the piece.
And it's--
- Did you say,
Lydia's sensuality?
- Well, I don't know entirely,
but, yes, I sense that.
I sense there is--
yes, I do.
I sense that there is some kind
of way in which the sport is
actually--
she's getting close to
the smell of the glove
and the crack of the bat.
And it's just so--
it's just-- you can touch it.
You can taste it.
And suddenly, those
desires are part of her.
And that becomes part of her
relationship with Alberga,
as well.
- We talked about that,
we talked about how--
and Martha and I talked
about that early on, too.
There's so much that Martha said
to me that works its way in.
And when I'm sitting next to
Martha, I'm like, oh, yeah,
I got that, mm-hmm--
about when somebody
does something
so at the top of their game,
there's a sexiness to it.
It's just hot to see somebody
do what they do really,
really well.
- And do it well.
- And it's an interesting thing
for the person playing Toni,
because in one
way she has this--
and this is all, this
is what I've made Toni.
I would not presume to--
The Toni that we have
created, based on the--
I just became very inarticulate.
What am I trying to say?
I don't know.
I entirely lost it.
It'll come back to me.
- Absolutely, I think--
- Well, what we start with?
I really want to--
I was going to do a
thing really good--
- I think--
- Something really good.
It was going to be good.
- Yeah feel like it's
related to the fact
that the choices that
you've made around Toni,
particularly related to,
is she on the spectrum.
It isn't how you necessarily
immediately think
of like the most sensual,
the most sexy person.
- That's what I
was going to say.
- But she is sexy when
she really, really excels
at what she does.
- Yes.
- And I was going
to say the challenge
for an actor of playing
someone who is disconnected
from herself, from her
body, and from the nuances
of how we interact socially, who
embodies the sport to which she
is so physically tied--
it's really beautiful to
watch and beautiful what
you did with it.
- The opening scene
was the first scene
you've shared with
me here at Radcliffe.
Whenever I came--
- So, the first thing,
we were drinking, right?
Is the first--
- No, we had that really
bad meal down at the--
- Oh, we did!
- Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
- But I had written
it on a little thing,
and I read it to you.
- Yeah, you read
it to me in Byerly,
And I was just blown away by it,
because it embodied so much--
not only that passion of when
you do something that you truly
love.
I mean, people always ask
me, what is this book about?
And, to a certain extent,
it's a love story,
but it's a love
story about work.
It's a love story
about what you do.
And not only does
that passion come out,
when you're talking
about the tactile nature
of the ball and the glove,
but it's also identity.
And that was completely
who Toni was.
Reporters often ask Toni,
what do you like best
about playing baseball?
And she always had
the same answer.
And she had this
high-pitched voice,
and you could tell there was
a sort of quickness to it.
I saw footage of her.
Her eyes would gleam.
And she said the most
benign, kind of mundane thing
about the sport.
She said, infield practice.
She said, I love
infield practice.
Well, when you think about it--
the ball lops first to third,
third to second, second
to catcher.
Boom, boom, rhythm,
rhythm, rhythm.
So, and then she said this.
She said, it's infield practice.
She said, it's
beautiful-- comma--
if it's played right.
You know?
So it was also--
it was poetry, it
was transcendence,
it was beauty for her.
- Wow.
- You see, every
time Martha talks--
and then, you have been so
generous through the process
of my writing it.
Because Martha will just be
supportive, just supportive.
And then you'll say
something like you just said.
And I was like,
why didn't I put--
OK, let me go back.
[LAUGHTER]
And then people say, wow,
Lydia that was so insightful.
And I'm like, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
- Well, the generosity
goes both ways.
This is the first time I've
ever had a book adapted
for the stage, and I
didn't know what role
I was supposed to play.
And I remember, we were doing
a workshop here at Radcliffe,
a couple of years ago.
And I can't remember the scene
anymore, but you turned to me,
and you asked me
about a verb tense.
And I was like
higher than a kite.
I got to pick the verb tense!
[LAUGHTER]
Oh, man!
That was fun.
- Well, I will
tell you that there
are people who generate the
source material who can not
be as generous.
You could have made
this process hell,
so I thank you for
not doing that.
- It goes both.
- Yeah, I--
- We shouldn't end on that.
- OK, I'll give you another.
Let's not, let's not, let not.
- Think we'll have
another debate.
- One other aspect that relates
to this notion of regularity
in the infield practice
is this idea that--
and this really comes
through in Toni's character--
about her trying to understand
the rules of baseball
and the rules of dating.
And I also-- this is, I imagine,
trying to understand the rules
that are part of being
in the Jim Crow era--
right-- where breaking those
rules have a really high cost.
And at some level, I think
we can think of sports again,
as sort of inculcating people
who play into a kind of system
of justice.
Where are these rules?
And there's an umpire, and
there's accountability.
And In baseball, there's
a special accountability,
because they're putting all the
negative things up on the board
about you.
And I was just wondering--
there's also this--
but you're also subverting
the fools, right?
The clowning, right?
There's a double consciousness
here, of you're watching me,
I'm watching you.
And you're also doing
this in the play.
You've got the men switching
from black to white.
You have them moving from
men to gender, as well.
Can you talk a little bit
about the idea of subversion
and the clowning in
this experience for you?
- Well, It's interesting.
There's an interesting
relationship
between being an
artist of color,
and making work
that acknowledges,
that talks about race
and gender and sexuality,
and how that interacts
with an audience.
And as my career has
progressed, and the houses
have become bigger and
fancier, the audiences
have become wider and wider.
And so, you can't make the
work that's about this thing
without acknowledging-- or
at least understanding--
the discomfort of the dynamic
and the tensions between how
you're going to interact with an
audience with regards to that.
And it's a dance, but I don't
think that the dance that
African-American, that
artists of color, that women,
that women artists of color,
that, I guess, white women--
you know, I think anyone who's--
oh, my God, I'm not
saying this very well.
I was.
I was on a roll, wasn't I?
I was really--
- Doing great.
- doing something.
But it's a peculiar dance.
And there's such a
parallel between the dance
that these amazing athletes
did, and the dance that we all
do to bring what
we do to audiences,
and the politics of that,
and where the politics meet
the art, and how
all of that works.
And so I couldn't-- it
just comes out in the play.
And I don't know that the play--
I noticed, today that I think--
or over the weekend,
I've noticed
that I don't know that the play
is quite excavating the joy.
I don't know how to put that
on stage, the ridiculous joy
of when the win happens.
And it doesn't right now,
when I try to put it--
I don't know how to do it yet.
It'll come to me.
But that's a part of
that dynamic, too,
the uncomfortable--
the dynamic, all of it.
Because in the
minstrelsy, there was joy.
And in the
African-American audiences,
watching the clowning, it's
a different kind of clowning.
It's a different
kind of laughter.
And it's an art form that's
appreciated for the art form
that it is, and becomes
something else depending
on the view of the audience.
And how exactly to capture that
for a white audience is tricky.
And that's probably where the
joy is lacking in the play,
because I don't know
how to do that, yet.
I guess I could just not let
white people come to the play.
[LAUGHTER]
That's one answer.
- Well there's one scene
that you didn't do today--
with the clowning--
that just pushes.
It pushes.
- Well, the
choreographer found that.
And it's such a
collaborative piece.
The choreographer
from a workshop
that we did in New
York found this thing
where the physical, the actual
physical, the exertion--
so it started out being
this beautiful funny kind
of movement that
was dance and light,
and through the sheer act of
the repetitive nature of it,
it became something else.
And then it became
something tragic.
And it was just--
and yeah.
So that was-- I hadn't written--
I didn't write that.
I wrote the passage that
we heard Steve read.
So it's just interesting--
- That is where
that dance comes.
- That's the dance.
- Well, I hope this workshop
has given you a chance
to really evaluate for
yourself the beauty
of the script and the gift that
you have giving to people here.
And I saw a lot of
joy in the cast,
and I hope that continues
to come through.
- Thank you.
- And maybe this is a good
now to open up to you all,
and to see if you
have some questions
that you'd like to ask.
And if you would, we have a
microphone here in the center,
if you'd come up.
Please feel free to
come up, ask a question.
We'd really appreciate it if you
would just identify yourself--
who you are, your name, and
then just ask a question.
- Hi my name is Laura, and I
was wondering about the choice
to make all of the cast other
than Toni be played by men,
in spite of the fact that
they go back and forth
between multiple genders.
- You tried to ask me that.
You did.
You asked me that.
That's a good question.
- If I may, I was hoping to hear
about it both from a directing
perspective and a
play-writing perspective,
as well as from the
acting perspective--
how it informed your
performance, as well.
- What was your name by the way?
- Laura.
- Thank you, Laura.
- Do you want to start?
- You start, and then I'll go.
- OK, I'll start.
Thank you for the question.
I toyed with if I wanted Toni to
be the only woman in the piece.
And then part of that whole
politic that we talked about,
around the making of theater
and the awareness of the politic
of the making of
theater, is that women
and African-American
women don't actually
get to be on the stage enough.
So the audacity of
making one role for that
play that will happen maybe
in February for one actress,
but you saw how
beautiful that was.
Just the act of putting eight
male bodies on a stage doing
something that is beautiful
and supporting a woman,
an African-American woman--
it felt like a really important
visual and a really important
gesture.
And it's fun to be in a
rehearsal room with eight
not-unattractive men.
[LAUGHTER]
So there's that.
- I also think that the--
so if you had a woman to
play [? Millie ?] and a woman
to play Mama, either they
aren't on the team or--
which to me is just marginalizes
them and their bodies further--
or they're playing
men on the team.
And that, to me, doesn't help
us with telling Toni's story.
Because Toni is on a
team of all male bodies,
and to me there's something
incredibly powerful
and-- as a woman--
incredibly powerful to see
her, to see her struggling,
to see her holding
her own, to see
her going through all
the things that she
goes through surrounded
by these guys.
And so for that reason
it feels right to me.
And then, I also am
moved by watching men
play women really respectfully.
We don't see that very often.
Usually men playing women is
just like surefire comedy.
Ha ha, that guy is
acting like a woman.
That is so funny, right?
It's just hilarious.
And, you know--
- And in particular,
that black men
have been asked to put
on dresses all the time.
And so, to have
the empowering act
of having an actor
be able to embrace
the beauty of his
mother, or his lover,
and not have that be something
perverted is a very striking.
And the arbitrary
nature of gender--
I think it says something
really interesting
about gender in general.
Because once she and
[? Millie ?] are in that room,
they are two women.
And I never-- and I
loved that Megan cast men
with beards as the women.
That was incredible.
So satisfying.
[LAUGHTER]
I meant that in a good way.
- I love what you say about
men playing women respectfully.
And just historically, one
of the ways that the Negro
Leagues had to do that dance--
through denigration-- was that
in the '30s, some of the teams
wore grass skirts.
- Grass skirts.
There's a scene that
talks about that.
Oh, you missed so
many good scenes.
You'll have to
come back to the--
there's a scene in which the
white owners of the teams
talk about that.
They have this whole
conversation about
is it OK to do
something that makes
Toni look good on the field.
Well, what it mean to baseball.
And yet there are
these white owners
making their employees do
this other kind of dance.
- To answer the question about
from an acting perspective,
for me--
where did she go?
Hi, sweetheart.
There's a moment of rehearsal,
where I'm like, ha ha,
is't that funny?
And then it goes away and I
don't even think about it.
And it's just the meet--
oh, sorry, mic-- it's
just the meeting of a
soul, souls of spirits
on another-- you know.
So I don't even process it.
Like the reading we did this
afternoon, and then the reading
we did just now, I don't
even think those are men.
It doesn't even occur to
me at all in the scene.
- And how quickly and
easily all of my casts
have come to embrace
that, with no control.
I thought there would
be some kind of thing
we would have to
do, around making
the actors feel comfortable in
their body and da-da, da-da,
da-da, da-da.
And immediately,
people are game.
Actors are so game, and just--
it's really kind of beautiful.
- Thank you very much for the
performance and for this panel.
It's fantastic.
My questions-- I bought
the book last year, Martha.
And I was curious
from listening to you
speak tonight, if it would
have made a difference when
you were doing the interviews,
if you had been a male.
Obviously you can't-- and
if you had been not white.
Do you think-- because you were
talking to a lot of the old
players--
- Right.
- --and I was wondering how
they interacted with you.
- Yeah.
Well, I was certainly aware
as I was writing the book
that I was a white
writer writing
about an African-American.
And the thing I constantly
reminded myself of
was what I didn't
know, and to be
able to have an openness to
learning everything I could.
I don't know that
in the interviews,
that I sensed that
gender or race would
have made a difference.
What I was greeted with,
again, and again, and again,
and again, was gratitude
for telling a story--
that somebody was getting
the story out there.
I relied a great deal
on a group called SABR--
the Society for American
Baseball Research,
which is a group of
researchers that kind of span
out to everything dealing with
baseball, including one dealing
with the Negro League.
And those guys
provided entree for me
for all of these older
players that I talked to.
No one ever treated
me as though I didn't
know what baseball was about.
They had to explain
things to me.
And I hope I entered
into those discussions
with, obviously, respect
and great curiosity for it.
So I guess my answer
to your question
is that I had an overwhelmingly
positive experience with it.
- Thank you.
- So I wanted to say
thanks, and ask you all
to join me to the
panelists, to the actors,
for this wonderful evening.
[APPLAUDING]
It's really a privilege
to get behind-the-scenes,
and to see a play in formation.
So thank you for being so
open and honest with us.
And I hope we'll see you all
back here tomorrow morning
at 9 for the conference.
Thanks.